let's now use our understanding of some
of the operations on sets to get some
blood flowing to our brains so I have to
find some sets here and just to make
things interesting I haven't only put
numbers in these sets I've even put some
colors and some little yellow stars here
and what I want you to figure out is
what would this set be this crazy thing
that it involves relative complements
intersections unions absolute
complements so I encourage you to pause
it and try to figure out what this set
would be well let's give it a shot and
the key here is to really break it down
work on the parentheses the stuff in the
parentheses first just as you would do
if you were trying to parse a
traditional mathematical statement and
then it should hopefully make a little
bit of sense so a good place to start
might be to try to figure out what is
the relative complement of C in B or
another way of thinking about this what
is B minus C what is B if you take out
all the stuff with C in it so let me
write this down the relative complement
of C and B or you could call this B
minus C this is all the stuff and B with
all the stuff and C taken out of it so
let's think about what this would be B
has a zero does C have a zero no so we
don't have to take out the zero B has a
17-2 C have a 17 yes it does so we take
out the 17 B has a three but C has a
three so we take that out B has a blue C
does not have a blue so we leave the
blue in so let me write down we leave
the blue in and then B has a gold star C
also has a gold star so we take the gold
star out so the relative complement of C
and B is just the set of zero and this
blue written in blue so let me write
this down let me write that down now it
gets interesting we're going to take the
absolute complement the absolute
complement of that so let me write this
down
so B be the relative the the absolute
complement of this business is going to
be all things all let me write it this
is the set of all things in our universe
set of all things in universe in
universe that are neither
that are neither a zero or a and I'll
write it in blue or a blue that's the
only way I can describe it right now I
haven't really defined the universe well
we already see that our universe
definitely contains some integers it
contains colors it contains some stars
so this is all I can really say this is
set of all things in the universe that
are neither a zero or a blue so fair
enough so we so far we figured out all
of this stuff all of this stuff let me
box this off so that is that right over
there and now we want to find the
intersection we need to find the
intersection of a and this business the
intersection of a and that business let
me write that down so it's going to be a
intersected with B the relative
complement of C and B and the absolute
complement of that so this is going to
be the intersection of the set a and the
set of all things in the universe that
are neither a 0 or a blue so it's
essentially the things that satisfy both
of these that has to be in set a and it
has to be in the set of all things in
the universe that are neither a zero or
a blue so let's think about what this is
so the number three is in set a and it's
in the set of all things in the universe
that are neither or zero or blue so
let's throw a three in there the number
seven it's an A and it's in the set of
all things in the universe that are
neither a zero or a blue so let's put a
7 there negative 5 also meets that
constraint zero does not meet that
constraint a zero is an A but it's not
in the set of all things in the universe
that are neither a zero or blue because
it is a zero so we're not going to throw
a zero in there and then a thirteen is
in a and it's in the set of all things
in the universe that are neither a zero
or a blue so we could throw a 13 in
there so we've simplified things a good
bit this whole crazy business all of
this crazy business has simplified to
this set right over here now we want to
find the relative complement of this
business in a so let me pick another
color here so we want to find the
relative complement of the
business in a so now I'll just write you
write out the set three seven negative
5/13 actually let me write out both of
them just to make it just so that we can
really just kind of visualize them both
right over here so a a is this it is
three seven negative 5 0 and 13 and I
could write the relative complement sign
or actually let me just write well let
me write relative complement I was going
to write minus and so in all of this
business we already figured out is a 3 a
7 negative 5 and a 13 so it's
essentially start with this set and take
out all the stuff that are in this set
so this is going to be equal to so you
see you have a you're gonna we're going
to have to take out a 3 out of this set
we're gonna take out a 7 we're going to
take out a negative 5 and we're take out
a 13 so we're just left with the set
that contains a 0 so all of this
business right over here has simplified
to a set that only contains 0 now let's
think about what B intersect C is B
intersect C these are all the things
that are in both B and C so this is
going to be B intersect C let's see we
don't 0 is not in both of them
17 is in both of them so we'll throw a
17 there the number 3 is in both of them
the number 3 is in both of them blue is
not in both of them the star is in both
of them so I'll put the little gold star
right over there and so that's B
intersect C and so we're essentially
going to take the union of this crazy
thing which ended up just being a set
with a zero in it we're taking the union
of that and B intersect C and we deserve
a drum roll now this is all going to be
equal to we're just going to combine
these two sets it's going to be the set
with a zero a 17 a 3 and our gold star
and our gold star and we are we are
looking at I should make the brackets in
a different color and we are done